you
hello and welcome from the royal swedish
academy of sciences where we just
discovered who has been awarded the 2010
labelled prize in physics joining me to
discuss this year's prize is Professor
Inc amar Lundstrom the chairman of the
Nobel Prize Nobel Prize Committee and
physics professor Lindstrom thank you
very much for joining us thank you could
we begin by you telling us who has
received the 2010 labelled prize in
physics yes the the prize was awarded to
Andre game and konstantin novoselov
University of Manchester for as we said
groundbreaking experiments regarding the
two-dimensional material graphene and so
what exactly is graphene graphene is
actually for normal people the building
blocks of of graphite the day sheets of
graphene makes up the graphite so when
we make a line of pencil pencil line
like that they have probably produce
graphene without knowing it because the
fein is the single mono layer of carbon
atoms and part of this pencil line would
actually also contain a single monolayer
so graphite exists as stats layers is
that what you're saying they yes it does
yeah it's like and graphene is one of
those layers you're correctly yeah and
you have another nice property show us
to show how graphene is that the if you
like to get a feeling for what graphene
is you can actually increase its lateral
dimensions with 100 million times and
then you will get the honey come or a
chicken wire like structure which would
be of this size 100 million times larger
than graphene and actually if you could
show that this line would be about only
three percent above the size of the
thickness of the this chicken bayonet
and what is interesting is that the the
two researchers and the co-workers they
started not to use graphene flakes which
are not bigger than the draft you have
in your hair but today you can produce
on plastic for use graphene sheets which
is the same width as this net so it
isn't tremendous development which has
occurred in six years because I didn't
tell you that the the groundbreaking
discovery was made in october two
thousand four so if we focus on that
discovery in october 2004 could you tell
us about how the researchers Isaac and I
could you tell us more about how
graphene was actually isolated yes it's
a very interesting story if I had their
piece of scotch tape it I could have
demonstrated it to you but what they did
was actually that they took a piece of
graphite a piece of carbon they put the
scotch tape on the on the carbon and
since graphite can be easily cleaved
they got graphite on the scotch tape and
then they except by by making this
procedure many times open and close the
tape they they got thinner and thinner
layers which I placed on an other
substrate which happen to be an oxidized
silicon crystal and what's the
importance of the oxidized silicon
crystal that that was the other other
invention they may they found out that
50 they oxidize the silicon to certain
thickness of oxide they could actually
see seeing a layer of carbon due to
interference changes in the interference
color so it was a very very ingenious
way of actually spotting a single layer
of graphene which made it possible for
them to isolate it and characterize it
and so what makes graphene such a
remarkable well it's it's if thin of
course it's light it's very strong it's
transparent and it's also a very good
conductor that means that revenus is
open for many many interesting
applications but it's also very
interesting material from a fundamental
point of view since this day
truly two-dimensional crystalline
material so could we go into those
applications in more detail please what
what exactly can researchers do with
graphene now well they are up or some
somebody very obvious applications where
they would add or other way so doing it
but where graphene would be superior
touch screens for example in solar cells
bendable electronics for gas sensors
being able to spot single molecules and
also recently been demonstrated that if
you make a pool in a sheet of graphene
you can actually use graphene to to
sequence DNA which may be another
possible future application of ography
so could you take us through health how
that's actually possible with graphene's
do all these applications d if i take
your last one every to sequence DNA is
the fact that then DNA molecule pauses
to the pool it you actually changed the
d current from the liquid on on one side
to the other side of the autograph
regime to change the conductivity i only
conductivity and that can then be
spotted and since graphene is very thin
the idea is that you could differentiate
between different base pairs because
they only be one base by forcing the the
same hole at the same time so it acts as
a sort of filter it acts as a filter
which also gives an electronic signature
and so how far are we with these these
applications are there any applications
on the market or are these just
potential applications I would say that
they are still has potential
applications i guessing i think the
touch screen application has comforters
but they are still not only in the
laboratories so we so we have discovery
of graphene and it has all these
potential tremendous applications but
there's still potential applications at
this point so what was it within the
group what was it the satisfied the
criteria of this discovery serving the
greatest benefit to mankind okay i guess
its first of all it's for me it's a
scientific physical baked breakthrough
being able to isolate the true two
dimensional crystalline material
the thinnest material in in in the earth
on earth and the second is that there
are enough potential applications at
this early stage which make me convinced
that graphene will find many many
commercial applications or using in the
near future and you mentioned in the
announcement that the discovery was made
six years ago yep and relatively
speaking is six years quite a short time
between discovery and Nobel Prize yes it
is normally I think there are longer
periods but if you go back in the in the
history you can find other prices which
have been rather early awarded I should
have a better memory than I have but i
think the the the scanning tunneling
microscope is one of these these
occasions when the price was awarded
quite early after of the discovery and
also high temperature superconducting
materials so given it's only been six
years between discovery in the prize and
given that there's potential
applications there's nothing yet on the
market what made this such a strong case
of the price this year it's actually
what I really said it was the discovery
of the isolation of the first through
two dimensional crystalline material and
a very large amount of already possible
applications of their only six years and
of course you could give him the prize
to one person or two three people as
under the stipulations of the prize what
made you decide to give it to just these
two researchers only well as you know
the deliberations in the in the Nobel
Committee irregular kept secret for 50
years so I think I we not to answer that
question in in in any detail but but you
said it was for this is fundamentally
for the paper that was published six
years ago and they don't breaking paper
yes and all and after that diamond /
sailor has also contributed a lot to to
further knowledge about the graphene but
the groundbreaking paper of october two
thousand four is actually the starting
point for our discussion of avoiding
them the price
and just to clarify the prize is
actually rewarding that specific paper
not not the specific paper is awarding
the the isolation I and identification
and characterization of the first truly
two dimensional crystalline material
which perhaps is more than that that
single paper and one thing you also
mentioned in the ounce Minh tis that
Andre Gaia's has also received an
ignoble price does that make him the
first person to receive the Nobel
ignoble double um I'm not sure because i
have in my back of my hand that there
are people have got the Nobel Prize
first and they've got the eagan Nobel
Prize later but that's not for me to say
but I certainly I think it's the first
one who gets the Iggy Nobel Prize first
and that the real Nobel Prize later and
my final question is have you had a
child speaks about laureates yes we
spoke to them by phone before this press
conference and I of course they were
both very happy and in different stages
of shock a guy Mosul don't think that
shot but i think the dino villanova
sailor was quite quite surprised quite
shocked and of course very happy he
happened to be the youngest Nobel Prize
winner since 1973 how old is he 36
vessel on strim thank you very much
thank you visit nobelprize.org to see
more information about this prize and to
listen to interviews with the new
laureates you can also receive news
updates from Nobel Prize org on Facebook
and Twitter channels and for the very
first time you can submit your questions
of issues lauritz on youtube visit
www.money Bell prize for more details we
look forward to receiving your questions
that's about it from this live webcast
join us tomorrow in the same room at the
royal swedish academy of sciences where
we will discover who will be awarded the
2010 nobel prize in chemistry that will
be at eleven-forty-five a.m. central
european time but in the meantime it's
goodbye from all of us at nobel prize
dot org
you